and to thin
and my ears stick out my teeth crooked
and my next much to him maybe so but I
love the way it all hangs together
throughout her career she was a symbol
of grace and beauty high style and high
spirits sophistication and sly innocence
to those of us who worked with her she
was a sensitive artist and a beautiful
cutter but there was a part of her life
that preoccupied her even more than her
acting career as a special ambassador
for UNICEF the United Nations Children's
Fund she tirelessly travelled the world
an advocate for the poor the
dispossessed she started for people who
probably never saw her radiance on
screen and maybe never would
Dayna
Audrey died earlier this year at the
young age of 63 and I last saw her she
was still astonishingly beautiful still
youthful still committed to her work
still the warm and adorable Audrey
Hepburn none of us will ever forget and
the children of the world and the
mothers of the world will never forget
her either never forget her compassion
her bravery a determination to
understand her high hopes her help
ladies and gentlemen Gregory
Jean Hersholt Humanitarian Award honors
individuals in the motion picture
industry whose humanitarian efforts have
brought credit to us all if ever someone
lived up to the ideals of this award the
dedication and conviction it was Audrey
Hepburn to accept the award on her
behalf
I'm honored to introduce Audrey's son
mr. Sean Hepburn Ferrer
Thank You Gregg on behalf of my mother
Thank You Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences colleagues and friends for
such a beautiful honor thank you to all
who wrote and thought of her during
these difficult times Thank You Connie
Doris and you bear for being such good
friends Gracia who kita my wife Lila my
brother Luca for completing the circle
of love Thank You UNICEF to everyone
from those in the offices in Geneva and
New York to the workers in the field
wherever you may be and Thank You Robbie
for being at her side she believed every
child has the right to health to hope to
tenderness and to life on her behalf I
dedicate this to the children of the
world thank